ja immer mehr restaurants dürfen jetzt
wieder öffnen in ganz deutschland unter
strengen auflagen in westfalen war es
schon so weit dass hahn restaurants
wieder offen heute ist es hier auch in
der hauptstadt soweit mein kollege peter
wilke ist jetzt für uns am
alexanderplatz peter wie ist es gerade
bei dir ist jetzt schon alles voll sind
die restaurants schon gut gefüllt
ja ich stehe hier beim hofbräu am
alexanderplatz in berlin noch ist es
noch nicht so voll
seit heute darf man hier wieder öffnen
allerdings unter strengen auflagen wir
können das ganze einfach mal anschauen
die gäste die hier ankommen müssen sich
an diesem pult melden sagen ob sie
drinnen oder draußen essen wollen und
dann bekommen sie wenn sie hier rein
gehen bekommen sie dieses dokument was
ausgefüllt werden kann nicht muss aber
die inhaber freuen sich natürlich wenn
sie es ausfüllen
da muss man den namen angeben die
anschrift die e mail adresse und die
telefonnummer und das soll dann helfen
wenn es zu einer infektion kommt die
infektionskette nachvollziehen zu können
ja dann gehen die gäste weiter rein in
das restaurant und werden gebeten sich
hier an diesem desinfektions spender die
hände zu desinfizieren das können wir
auch einfach mal kurz machen
und ja dann können die gäste entweder
weiterhin ein dort sind auch die
ausgängen getrennt mit dem eingang
rechts und dem ausgang links oder eben
in den biergarten
das wollen wir jetzt einfach mal dann
auch machen einem in den biergarten
gehen und hier hinein schauen wie wir
sehen können sind auch hier die tische
mit dem mindestabstand von 1,5 meter
penibel abgemessen und voneinander
getrennt und ja darüber wollen wir jetzt
sprechen mit dem inhaber des hofbräu
kern büren schwarz herr schwarz wir
haben jetzt schon gesehen wie sich die
gäste hier verhalten müssen wenn sie zu
ihm kommen wie haben sie sich denn als
inhaber in den letzten tagen auf die
öffnungen vorbereitet ja es gibt ein
maßnahmenplan der dehoga den haben wir
als zivile konzept zugrunde gelegt und
haben trainings mit unseren mitarbeitern
gemacht wo die abstände einzuhalten sind
wie man das mit der hygiene genau zu
händeln hat wenn man reinkommt wie man
die gäste bedient um wie man die tisch
ab und wir sehen jetzt die tische sind
weit auseinander mit dem mindestabstand
das ist halt natürlich auch weniger
plätze wie viele gäste können sie
normalerweise hier begrüßen wie viele
jetzt und mit wie vielen gästen rechnen
sie heute normalerweise begrüßen wir
freitags abends heute ist ja fast 1500
gäste in etwa heute ist es gerade mal
ein zehntel
durch die haus- heiz regelung lässt es
sich schwer vorhersagen wie viele gäste
im haus kommen können denn pro tisch
kann ein haushalt jahr aus zwei drei
vier oder fünf personen bestehen wenn
alle tische nur mit zwei personen
besetzt sind haben wir entsprechend
weniger kapazität wenn größere haushalte
kommt mehr kapazität und würden sie
sagen dass sich das ganze überhaupt
wirtschaftlich lohnt wenn sie jetzt
weniger personen begrüßen können und
auch auf so viele maßnahmen achten
müssen selbstverständlich ist eine
schwierige frage eine schwierige
situation aber wir brauchen diese
perspektive wir brauchen diese eröffnung
unbedingt um einen anfang zu haben und
hoffen natürlich mittelfristig wieder
dass die lockerungen sich durchsetzen
und dass das ganze wieder sinn macht